My mother always jokes that she didn't ever really believe I graduated until she got the diploma. And even then, she like gave the diploma a good hard look and she was like, is this something that he could have fabricated? Wow. Yeah. She's Bryce's mom. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 44, recorded on September 11th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we reminisce about our university days and opine on whether or not you should drop out of university. I actually, when I graduated, I had to fly back from Toronto to Vancouver. And I did it mostly for my parents.
我母亲总是开玩笑说，直到拿到毕业证她才真正相信我毕业了。即使在那时，她也会仔细端详那张毕业证，然后说：这东西该不会是他自己伪造的吧？哇。没错。她是布莱斯的妈妈。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 44 期，录制于 2021 年 9 月 11 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起回忆我们的大学时光，并就你是否应该大学辍学发表了看法。实际上，我毕业时，不得不从多伦多飞回温哥华。我这么做主要是为了我的父母。
And they gave me that degree thing. And it did not mention. All it said was Bachelor of Science. Nothing about Actuarial Science. I was so disappointed. I handed it to my mother. And I said, you can have this. I can't believe they just painted us all with the same brush.
他们给了我那个学位证。上面却没有提及任何专业。上面只写了理学学士。什么精算科学都没有。我太失望了。我把它交给我母亲。我说，这东西归你了。我真不敢相信他们竟然把我们所有人一概而论。
Like, I suffered. I had a friend at Lsu got a degree in um it was biomedical or biochemical engineering or something um i don't remember what it was specifically but it was something in that area but the the actual thing that they put on his diploma um for for the degree area was not like the thing that people in the industry were looking for and so like he had a degree in the area but he wasn't able to get a job in the field because the spelling of the degree was just not not the one that folks were looking for like maybe it was yeah i don, I don't remember what it was specifically, but like maybe it was that the word engineer wasn't in there and that he had gotten an engineering degree,
就像我吃过的苦。我有个在路易斯安那州立大学的朋友拿到了一个学位，嗯，是生物医学或生物化学工程之类的，嗯，我记不清具体是什么了，但反正是那个领域的。然而，他们印在他毕业证上的学位专业名称，并不是业界人士所寻找的那种。所以，虽然他在该领域拥有学位，但他在该行业找不到工作，因为该学位的拼写根本不是人们所寻找的。也许是，嗯，我记不清具体是什么了，但也许是因为里面没有“工程师”这个词，而他明明获得的是工程学位，
but it didn't have engineer in there and that caused problems for him. But it was funny. I didn't go to my graduation. And as you listeners know, I dropped out of college the first time around. And then when I ended up working at a research center at LSU and my boss basically tricked me into going back to school and getting a degree by essentially telling me it was the only way I could remain employed for him long term. So I was like, sure, fine, I'll go take a few classes. And then like eventually I had enough credits to graduate. But I had met all the requirements of the LSU College of Science to get the degree.
但里面却没有“工程师”字样，这给他带来了麻烦。但这挺有意思的。我没有去参加毕业典礼。正如听众们所知，我第一次上大学时就辍学了。后来，当我在路易斯安那州立大学的一个研究中心工作时，我的老板基本上是诱骗我回去上学并拿到学位，他本质上告诉我，这是我能长期为他工作的唯一途径。所以我想，好吧，行吧，我去上几门课。然后，不知不觉我就有足够的学分毕业了。但我已经满足了路易斯安那州立大学理学院获得学位的所有要求。
And taking all the classes, I turned my terrible gpa into a less terrible gpa because when i dropped out my gpa was one which is bad for those who are that's academic probation but yeah but so i i went to like tell me like this was 2014 into the fall semester i was done I'd done all the credits. And I go to tell the College of Science, like, hey, like I'm, you know, I should be good to go now. And they tell me, no, no, no, no. You've met all the requirements. But to get a degree from the College of Science, you must have taken a certain number of credit hours while registered as a student of the College of Science.
修完所有课程后，我把我那糟糕的绩点变成了一个没那么糟糕的绩点，因为当我辍学时，我的绩点是 1，对于那些了解的人来说这很糟糕，那是学术留校察看，但是，是的，所以我去告诉他们——这大约是 2014 年秋季学期，我完成了，我已经修完了所有学分。我去找理学院说，嘿，我觉得我应该没问题了。他们告诉我，不，不，不，不。你已经满足了所有要求。但要获得理学院的学位，你必须在注册为理学院学生期间修满一定数量的学分。
And you only registered as a student of the College of Science like one semester ago. And I was like, but I've taken all my required coursework. And they're like, yeah, but like you've got to take six credit hours more. So I was like, all right, well, like fine, whatever. Or is that two courses? Yeah, so I took like two courses during the winter break. And my parents were not thrilled that I didn't come home to visit them, but I'm like, I'm just gonna take the two easiest courses and then just like be out of here.
而你注册为理学院的学生才一个学期。我说，但我已经修完了所有要求的课程。他们说，是的，但你还得再修六个学分。所以我当时想，好吧，随便吧，反正就这样。或者那是两门课？对，所以我利用寒假上了两门课。我的父母对我没有回家看望他们感到很不高兴，但我想，我只想选修两门最简单的课程，然后赶紧离开这里。
And long story short, because of that, they do have a graduation ceremony at the end of the fall semester, because it's a giant school. So some number of people graduate at that time. But I missed out on that one because I didn't technically graduate at the end of the fall semester. I graduated at the end of the winter, like intersession.
长话短说，正因为如此，由于这是一所大型学校，他们在秋季学期末会举办一场毕业典礼。所以当时有一部分人毕业了。但我错过了那场典礼，因为严格来说，我在秋季学期结束时并没有毕业。我是寒假结束时才毕业的。
And then, like, I left Louisiana. And at the time, I was not particularly enamored with Louisiana. So I had no interest in going back to actually walk for my graduation. So I didn't actually go to my college graduation but my mother um she i had the the diploma mailed to them because i had i had just moved and i didn't have a mailing address yet i i hadn't found a place to live in berkeley yet my my mother always jokes that she didn't ever really believe i graduated until she got the diploma and even then she like gave the diploma a good hard look and she was like is this something that he could have fabricated?
然后，我离开了路易斯安那州。当时，我对路易斯安那州并没有什么好感。所以我根本没兴趣回去参加毕业典礼。所以我其实并没有去参加大学毕业典礼，但我母亲，嗯，我让把毕业证寄给他们，因为我刚搬家，还没有邮寄地址，我还没在伯克利找到住处。我母亲总是开玩笑说，直到拿到毕业证她才真正相信我毕业了，即使在那时，她也会仔细端详那张毕业证，然后说：这东西该不会是他自己伪造的吧？
Wow. Jeez, Bryce's mom. That's, uh... I believe in you, Bryce. I believe in you. Even if your mother doesn't. I think you perhaps don't understand how devious I was as a child. LSU's in New Orleans, right?
哇。天哪，布莱斯的妈妈。这，呃……我相信你，布莱斯。我相信你。即使你母亲不相信。我想你可能不明白我小时候有多淘气。路易斯安那州立大学在新奥尔良，对吧？
Or however the Americans say it. But that's also why I'm bothered that my diploma says I graduated in 2015 because that's not actually correct. I was done with college like December 2014, but they issued my diploma, you know, the next semester. Look at that. I graduated before you um did you when did you graduate it took me six years because I I did a year abroad and I also
或者美国人是怎么叫它的。但这也是为什么我对我的毕业证上写着我于 2015 年毕业感到不爽，因为这其实不对。我在 2014 年 12 月左右就大学毕业了，但他们是在下个学期才颁发毕业证的。你看。我比你早毕业，你是什么时候毕业的？我花了六年时间，因为我做了一年的交换生，我还
did a bunch of internships um so technically I only did eight semesters academically um but yeah I I started in 2008 September 2008 and I graduated in May 2014. Yeah, I think I actually only really did like 2.5 years as a college student. I had like one year where I took like a handful of courses and then I had a bunch of credits from high school but then like once I made the decision at LSU that I was going to get a degree I just took like an insane number of courses um like more courses I I think I found some way to take more courses a semester than you were supposed to be allowed to take. And I, yeah, but I took a very high course. I was just like, I just want to be done with this crap. So this is this is great.
做了一堆实习，所以严格来说我在学术上只读了八个学期。但是，是的，我是从 2008 年 9 月开始的，2008 年 9 月入学，2014 年 5 月毕业。是的，我想我实际上作为大学生只读了大约 2.5 年。我有一年的时间只选修了寥寥几门课，然后我从高中带过来一堆学分。但一旦我在路易斯安那州立大学做出决定要拿一个学位，我就开始疯狂地选修大量课程，选修的课程比你一个学期被允许选修的课程还要多，我想我找到了某种方法，每个学期能选修比规定上限更多的课程。是的，我修了非常多的课程。我当时的想法就是：我只想赶紧摆脱这破事。所以这真的很棒。
So we we are we have similar notes of similarity in our backgrounds, as I mentioned last episode. And then I said it stopped at the credenza and the furniture and the decorator. But now we're back because I also, similar to you, didn't really pay close enough attention to the requirements to graduate. And I signed my full-time offer in like October or November of 2013 and told my employer that I was at a co-op at the time that, yeah, I should be able to graduate in a single semester. I had planned to do two more because I needed six courses and a bunch of them were hard. But they basically said, like, if you can do it in one, like we don't care about your grades. You'll have signed the offer just like if you want to come back. And I said, sure.
所以我们在背景上有很多相似之处，正如我在上一集所提到的。然后我说这些相似之处止于长餐具柜、家具和室内设计师。但现在我们又回到了这个话题，因为我也和你一样，没有对毕业要求给予足够的关注。我在 2013 年 10 月或 11 月左右签署了我的全职工作Offer，并告诉我当时的实习雇主，我应该能够在单个学期内毕业。我原本计划再读两个学期，因为我需要修六门课程，而且其中很多课程都很难。但他们基本上说，如果你能在一年内搞定，我们不在乎你的成绩。只要你想回来，Offer随时生效。我说，行。
So I went, signed up for my six courses and then applied for graduation like in the January. And then they I got rejected. And then I got rejected. And then I was like, what are you talking about? I'm good to go. And they said, you're missing similar to you. I had all the right number of credits, but I had missed that I needed a certain number of upper division credits.
于是我去了，注册了我的六门课程，然后在 1 月份左右申请了毕业。然后我被拒绝了。然后我又被拒绝了。当时我就想，你在说什么？我已经没问题了。他们说，你还差一点，跟你一样。我的学分总数完全足够，但我忽略了自己还需要一定数量的高年级学分。
So 300 or 400 courses. And I was short by one credit. And so I had to take a seventh course, which was not allowed. You're only allowed to take a maximum of six. But there's one exception. If you're in the final semester and that seventh course is necessary for you to graduate, you can get permission from the registrar's office. So I went to, I believe Sandy was her name. She's a lovely lady. And I sort of begged. I said, hey, I have this offer. I'd like to go make money. And it was a pretty bad semester. I would have been put on academic probation. I finished with a 1.8 GPA that term. And I'm
也就是 300 或 400 级的课程。我差了一个学分。所以我不得不选修第七门课程，这是通常不允许的。你最多只能选修六门。但有一个例外。如果你处于最后一个学期，并且第七门课程是你毕业所必需的，你可以获得教务处的许可。所以我去找了她，我想她叫桑迪。她是一位可爱的人。我有点苦苦哀求。我说，嘿，我得到了这份Offer。我想去赚钱。那是一个相当糟糕的学期。我差点就被留校察看了。那个学期结束时我的绩点只有 1.8。我
pretty sure a couple of my- 1.8 GPA club. We're, yeah, I feel like we're setting bad role models for any of the university kids that are listening. Don't do what we did. Go to your classes. Don't drop out of college. I actually get a surprising number of people that DM me and ask me about whether they think it's a good idea for them to drop out of college because I did it and, you know, turned out all right. And I have also advocated that, you know, I think at least for me, I didn't really learn anything in college. It was a very miserable experience. I really didn't enjoy it. I did not enjoy the whole system. did not enjoy um the fact that they tried to you know
敢肯定我的——1.8 绩点俱乐部的成员。我们，是的，我觉得我们给任何收听的大学生树立了坏榜样。不要像我们这样。去上课吧。不要从大学辍学。实际上，有数量惊人的私信发给我，询问他们是否认为辍学是个好主意，因为我这么做了，而且，你知道，结果也挺好。而且我也一直主张，你知道，至少对我而言，我在大学里其实没学到什么东西。那是一段非常悲惨的经历。我真的很不喜欢它。我不喜欢整个体制。不喜欢
make me conform to this system i did not enjoy all the arbitrary requirements i didn't enjoy being treated like five-year-old um you know i they wait they treat you as five-year-olds i guess that's sort of how i feel like you know like are you man are you mandated to show up to class in america no yeah i just i just mean that like you know like like they tell you like are you man are you mandated to show up to class in america no yeah i just i just mean that like you know like like they tell you like oh you can't take you know you can only take this many credit they don't treat you like an adult and at the time that i was going to college um when i was at lsu i was like working a full-time job and like i was running a computer lab at one of LSU's research centers. So I wasn't really like in the college phase of my life.
他们试图让我顺应这个体制，我讨厌所有随心所欲的要求，我讨厌被当成五岁小孩对待，你知道，他们把你当成五岁小孩，我想这就是我的感受，就像，你知道，在美国你必须去上课吗？没有。是的，我的意思是，你知道，就像他们告诉你，哦，你不能选，你知道，你只能选这么多学分。他们不把你当成年人看待。在我上大学的时候，当我在路易斯安那州立大学时，我做着一份全职工作，我还管理着路易斯安那州立大学其中一个研究中心的计算机实验室。所以我不大像是处于大学生活阶段的人。
It was just like a thing that like I had to do. It's a hoop. Yeah. And like I've never really been a big believer in traditional education systems. And I just didn't feel like I learned much from school. But anyway, so a lot of people will ask me privately about, you know, whether I think they should drop out of school or not. And I actually, I don't frequently advise people to do that.
那只是一件我不得不做的事情。那只是一个形式。是的。而且我从来不是传统教育体制的坚定信仰者。我只是觉得我从学校里学不到什么东西。不管怎样，很多人会私下来问我，关于他们是否应该辍学。实际上，我并不经常建议别人这么做。
And here's just some of the reasons why. Well, first of all, a lot of people contact me and ask whether they should drop out of school when they're like two or three years in. And as much as I hate college and hate like the modern education system and think it like fundamentally needs to be reformed. If you're like three or two years in and you've got like one year left to complete it, one, you've already sunk a huge amount of time and money into getting that degree. And like there is a tangible benefit that it'll have in your career for you to actually have been a college graduate. Like you can survive as not a college graduate, but there is some benefit to just having it on your resume.
原因有以下几个。首先，很多人联系我，询问他们是否应该在读了两三年的时候辍学。尽管我讨厌大学，讨厌现代教育体制，并认为它从根本上需要改革。如果你已经读了三年或两年，只剩一年就能读完了，首先，你已经在获取这个学位上投入了大量的时间和金钱。拥有大学学历确实会对你的职业生涯产生切实的好处。不拿大学学位你也能生存，但简历上有个学位确实有好处。
You know, it does open up some doors. It does. Especially if you want to travel and like and work abroad, like having a degree is a big thing. We're going to get to that in a minute. We'll get to that whole thing in a minute. But just like there is like even though even though I don't think that the college experience is very valuable, I do think that the college experience is very valuable i do think
它确实能为你打开一些大门。确实如此。特别是如果你想去旅游并在国外工作，拥有一个学位是一件大事。我们一会儿就会谈到这一点。我们一会儿会讨论整个事情。但只是，即使——尽管我认为大学经历并没有那么有价值，但我确实认为——大学经历非常有价值，我确实认为
that the degree is very valuable hold away pause what do you mean by college do you mean the classes or do you mean like the the period of your life that is college attached to that because i think those are two different things really yeah okay yeah um continue at least just for me it like it was not the right life experience um like i recognize that for some people it is, but, um, I just, it's just not an environment I ever liked. Um, but so if you're more than 50% of the way through this investment, both in terms of investment of your time and investment of your money, um, I think the bar is really, really got to be large for you to drop out. And I've had some people who have contacted me in their last one or two semesters saying,
这个学位非常有价值。等等，暂停。你说的大学是指课程，还是指作为大学附属的那段生活？因为我觉得这是两回事，真的。好吧，好吧，呃……请继续。至少对我来说，这不是一段正确的生活经历——我知道对某些人来说是这样的，但是，呃，我只是——这根本不是我喜欢的环境。呃，所以如果你已经完成了这项投资的 50% 以上，无论是时间投资还是金钱投资，呃，我觉得要想辍学，门槛真的必须要非常非常高。有些人联系我时已经读到最后的一两个学期了，他们说：
hey, look, I got this job that's lined up and they want me to just like quit school and come work for them and and i i i i think that it's really unwise and unfair for companies to offer to do that because like if if somebody is like one semester away from finishing like just they should just finish yeah just do it yeah like you know even even if you're miserable in college if you've made it to the point where you've got like one year or two years left you should just finish like it's almost always the right decision for you to just finish um because the opportunity cost is pretty low like i get there are some circumstances where i could see it being the right call like if you told me that your buddies were going to do a startup and that like you want
嘿，你看，我找到了一份工作，他们想让我直接退学去给他们工作。而且我觉得公司提出这种要求真的很不明智也很不公平，因为如果有人只差一个学期就要毕业了，他们就应该直接读完。是的，直接读完吧。是的，就像，你知道，即使你在大学里过得很痛苦，如果你已经坚持到了只剩一两年就能毕业的地步，你还是应该把它读完。因为几乎在任何情况下，直接读完都是正确的决定。因为机会成本相当低。我明白在某些情况下这可能是个正确的选择，比如如果你告诉我你的死党们要创业，而且你真的很
you really believed in it and you wanted to get in on the ground floor um and that like you know it was something where you couldn't wait a year or you'd just completely miss out sure fair enough um but uh but yeah so so that's the first thing is most people come and ask me about um whether they should go to whether they should finish college you you know, partway through. And I sort of get that because think about it. Almost nobody is thinking about not going to college or I should say for people that have the means to go to college. You're not thinking about not going in your first year or before you even go normally because you haven't realized at that point that it wasn't the right
相信这个项目，并且你想从基层做起，而且，你知道，这是一个你无法等上一年的项目，否则你就会彻底错过机会，那好吧，情有可原。呃，但——是的，所以这是第一点，大多数人来找我咨询关于他们是否应该去——是否应该在中途完成大学学业。我某种程度上能理解这一点，因为你想想。几乎没有人会考虑不上大学，或者我应该说，对于有条件上大学的人来说。你在第一年或者甚至在你入学之前通常不会考虑不去上学，因为在那之前你还没意识到这不适合你。
thing for you. Like it's natural that the time that you're going to start thinking about whether you should finish college is when you're 50% of the way through. Because that's the point where like you've been there long enough that the honeymoon period's worn off and like you've learned some stuff and maybe now you have some other opportunities lined up. So like it's very natural at that phase to start thinking about, yeah, maybe I don't need to do this. It's not natural for you to realize like immediately your first semester in college, like, oh, this is miserable. I don't want to do that. But if you did go to one semester of college and you just thought it was miserable and you had some other opportunities lined up, like that's a circumstance where I might recommend
因此，当你进行到一半时，你开始考虑是否应该读完大学，这是非常自然的事情。因为在这个阶段，你在那里待的时间足够长，蜜月期已经过去，你学到了一些东西，也许现在你面前有了其他机会。所以在那个阶段开始思考“是的，也许我不需要这么做”是非常自然的。你不太可能在大学第一个学期就立刻意识到：哦，这太痛苦了，我不想读了。但如果你真的上了一个学期的大学，觉得它非常痛苦，并且你面前还有其他机会，那么在这种情况下，我可能会建议你辍学。我需要对你的情况有更多的了解。
that you drop out. I'd have to learn a lot more about your situation. And that's the other thing, which is one of the first things I ask somebody if they're talking to me about dropping out in college is I basically I want to know, are they or are they not a white male from the U.S. or a certain set of European countries that have preferential immigration status to the rest of the world. Because if you are not a white male from either the US or Canada or like a European country in the Schengen area, then not having a college degree is going to have real impact on your ability to immigrate and your ability to get a job. Like if you're a white guy who's a college dropout in the US, like you're going to be fine. You're going to probably be fine, you know. But if you're, you know, a black woman, that is going to have much more of a real impact on on your ability to get a job
这就是另一件事了，如果有人跟我谈论大学辍学，我问他们的第一个问题之一就是：我基本上想知道，他们是不是来自美国或某些对世界其他地方享有优先移民地位的欧洲国家的白人男性。因为如果你不是来自美国、加拿大或申根区欧洲国家的白人男性，那么没有大学学位将会对你的移民能力和找工作能力产生真正的实质影响。如果你是个在美国辍学的白人小伙，你大概会过得不错。你大概会没事的。但如果你是个，你知道的，黑人女性，那将对你的求职能力产生大得多的实际影响。
and so maybe for you the degree is actually more valuable um and like especially when it comes to matters of immigration um i know some really some really really smart people um who do not live in the u.s um and like in particular some of my my friends and colleagues who live in nigeria these guys you know what one of them i think you know do you know bassett yeah yeah yeah absolutely brilliant guy um but you know he's he's had a hard time, um, uh, getting internships because of the country that he's based in. Even, even in remote work times, you know, it can be challenging for people who are not in the U.S. because if you're, if you live in, uh, Nigeria or if you live in, I'm trying to think of another country that would be a good example, say Iran, you know, all of the big, it's possible that the big multinational tech companies may not even have operations in that country. So even if they'd be willing to give you a remote internship, they may not have the capability to do so because HR does not have a way to set that up.
所以对你来说，学位实际上可能更有价值。而且，特别是在移民问题上，我认识一些非常非常聪明的人，他们不住在美国，尤其是我的几位朋友和同事，他们住在尼日利亚。这些人，你知道的，其中有一个我想你认识，你知道巴西特吗？对，对，绝对是个才华横溢的家伙。但你知道，因为他所在的国家，他在寻找实习机会时遇到了很多困难。甚至在远程工作时代，对于不在美国的人来说也是充满挑战的。因为如果你住在尼日利亚，或者如果你住在——我想另一个好例子是什么国家——比如伊朗，所有的这些大型跨国科技公司甚至可能在该国没有业务。所以即使他们愿意为你提供远程实习，他们也可能没有能力这样做，因为人事部门没有办法安排。
And then, you know, figuring out how to get an immigration visa like is really tough. It's become a lot tougher in recent years. And it's much harder when you don't have a degree. Especially if you're from, you know, a certain set of countries that have extra, extra restrictions on them. Like I, the research group I used to work in, in LSU, we had a lot of Iranian students and most of them got their master's in Iran. Some of them were undergrads who came over, but it was just, it was, let me tell you, it's real tough to get into the U.S. on a student visa if you're from Iran. Yeah. And, and yeah, so, so it's weird,
然后，弄清楚如何获得移民签证真的很艰难。近年来，这变得更加艰难。当你没有学位时，这就更难了。特别是如果你来自某些受到额外限制的国家。比如我以前在路易斯安那州立大学工作的研究小组，我们有很多伊朗学生，他们大部分是在伊朗获得硕士学位的。其中有些人是过来读本科的，但情况就是这样，我告诉你，如果你来自伊朗，想要获得学生签证去美国是真心的难。是的，而且——所以，这很奇怪，
but I, the college dropout who has spoken about how I I do not enjoy college frequently. I oftentimes find myself advising people that perhaps they should stick around and finish out school. Yeah, I I completely agree. I don't think I had the like we didn't have super similar experiences like i was not a big fan of yeah the traditional education system i had a couple really really good professors like gary parker dr gary parker he was um i took two or three actuarial mathematics courses with him he by far was the best professor i've i had in university and and actually treated, he treated all of his students, not just with as like as adults, but he, he expected you to like elevate yourself to, you know, whatever,
但我这个经常说自己不喜欢大学的大学辍学生，却经常发现自己建议别人或许应该留下来把书念完。是的，我完全同意。我不认为我有过这样的经历——我们的经历并不十分相似。我不是传统教育体制的狂热粉丝。我有几位非常非常好的教授，比如加里·帕克（Gary Parker）博士。我跟他修过两三门精算数学课程。他绝对是我在大学里遇到的最好的教授，实际上他对待所有的学生，不仅仅是把他们当作成年人，他还期望你能提升自己，达到你人生中所在的任何水平。
wherever you were at in your life. You know, I remember one of the first things he said in, uh, ACMA 320, which was sort of the, once you conditionally or unconditionally got into the program, um, he said in the first lectures, he says, you know, I'm going to do my best. And all I ask is that you do yours. And he just he cared so much about his students. And so I had a couple really good professors. But a lot of professors aren't great, you know, they're not there to teach, they're there to do their research. And they just, they have to do teaching as a part of it. I think that's the case. But, you know, I don't think that I don't think that my problem with college was necessarily, you know, a problem with my professors. I had a number of really good professors. One of my I took a bunch of philosophy and religious studies classes at LSU.
我记得在 ACMA 320（这是一门当你条件性或无条件性进入该专业后要上的课）的第一堂课上，他说的一句话是：我将尽力而我唯一的请求是你们也尽力。他太关心他的学生了。所以我遇到了几位非常好的教授。但很多教授并不出色，你知道，他们来这里不是为了教书，而是为了做研究。他们教书只是工作的一部分。我想情况就是这样。但是，你知道，我不认为我对大学的问题必然出在教授身上。我有很多非常好的教授。我在路易斯安那州立大学修了一堆哲学和宗教研究课程。
And that was those were like the one set of classes that I really found rewarding. And I had a really great professor, um, who taught them. Um, and there were a bunch of other professors that I, I worked with or interacted with who were very, um, you know, they were very good. Um, I, I certainly, I had, I had a handful who were quirky or who were clearly very smart, but they were not educators or they had just not been trained to educate, which I think is one of the problems with the system, which is just because you have a PhD in physics does not mean you have the training to teach physics. Like I took a comp sci course in data structures and the class was going too slowly. So they decided to skip hash tables. Hash tables for a number of years was a data structure that I had heard of. And all I knew of it is that was the data structure we skipped. And fast forward to one point I was interviewing
那些是我真正觉得有收获的一类课程。我有一位非常棒的教授教这些课。还有很多其他教授，我跟他们共事过或交流过，他们都非常，你知道，他们非常优秀。我当然遇到过一些性格古怪或者明显非常聪明但却不是教育家的人，或者他们根本没有受过教育培训。我认为这也是体制的问题之一，仅仅因为你拥有物理学博士学位并不意味着你接受过教授物理学的培训。比如我上过一门关于数据结构的计算机科学课程，那节课进度太慢了。所以他们决定跳过散列表。散列表是我听说过好几年的数据结构。我对它的全部了解就是，它是我们跳过的那种数据结构。快进到有一次我去谷歌面试，
at Google and I had an onsite. This was way, way early when I had just sort of trying to switch from actuary to tech and they sent you these documents and one of the things in the documents was like out of all the data structures that you should know coming to the you know interviews where we're going to ask you a lot of algorithms data structures problems know the hash table like know how to implement a simple hash table is by far the most important or hash table hash map whatever you want to call it is is the most important uh data structure and i was just like laughing when i read that because i was like oh yeah that you mean the data structure that my prof skipped because we
我参加了现场面试。那是很早很早以前，当我刚开始试图从精算师转行到科技行业时，他们发给你这些文件。文件中的内容之一是：在来到面试现场需要了解的所有数据结构中（我们要问你很多算法和数据结构的问题），一定要懂散列表——知道如何实现一个简单的散列表，这绝对是最重要的，或者叫散列表、哈希映射，随便你怎么称呼，它是最重要的数据结构。当我读到那段时，我简直笑出了声，因为我想：哦，对，就是那个由于我们没有时间而被我的教授跳过的数据结构。
didn't have time uh we we went through all the different flavors of the red black trees and the self-sorting and blah blah blah um well that's another, that's an example of another problem, which is the people at the university that are teaching the classes are not always the people who know what skills you need, like what skills are currently in demand in the industry. Yeah, well, that's, that's a, that's been a problem for forever. It's like, especially with CS, it's always lagging by, you know, if you're lucky, five years. If you're not, it's lagging by, you know. I don't think, I've actually heard of a couple universities in Europe.
我们学了红黑树的各种变体、自排序等等，等等。好吧，那是另一个问题的例子，也就是大学里教课的人并不总是知道你需要什么技能的人，比如目前行业中真正需要什么技能。是的，好吧，那一直是个老问题了。就像，特别是计算机科学领域，它总是落后，如果你幸运的话，落后五年。如果不幸的话，它落后得更多。我不认为——我其实听说欧洲有几所大学。
Like Ivan Chukich, if I probably mispronounced that name. But, you know, the author of Functional Programming in C++. I know he, at one point is, I think he's sort of still a professor. He works at KDAB. I think maybe he's moved to somewhere else. But I know that there's a couple of profs in Europe that teach modern C++. But it's far and few between that you're going to find a course that actually teaches you, you know, the standard library you know algorithm data you know data structure headers and whatnot and uh it's it's mostly like the implementation of just some
比如伊万·丘基奇（Ivan Čukić），我可能把这个名字念错了。但是，你知道，《C++ 函数式编程》的作者。我知道他，曾经有一段时间，我想他现在某种程度上还是个教授。他在 KDAB 工作。我想他可能搬到别的什么地方去了。但我知道欧洲有几位教授在教现代 C++。不过你要想找到一门真正教你标准库算法、数据结构头文件等的课程，还是少之又少的。它基本上就是对某种通用东西的实现，
generic thing and they're like choose whatever language you want and how often are you going to be actually implementing a red black tree for work no like every language you know java has your tree map c++ has your whatever, maps and sets. And not that that stuff's not valuable, but there's another version of a course that they could give that would be so much more useful. So wait, so you said you didn't have a problem with the courses. So why? I think one of my fundamental – well, I didn't have a problem with the teachers. I did have a problem with the courses.
他们会说：选择你想要的任何语言。你工作中会有多少次需要自己去实现红黑树呢？不会的。每种语言（你知道的，Java 有你的 TreeMap，C++ 有你的各种 Map 和 Set）都有现成的。并不是说那些东西没有价值，但他们完全可以开设另一门更有用的课程。等等，所以你刚才说你对课程没有意见。那么为什么？我认为我的根本问题之一——好吧，我对老师没有意见。我对课程确实有意见。
And one of the reasons that I have a problem with the courses is because courses are graded um and i understand the rationale for why it is necessary to um grade students but um i do not think that it produces desirable outcomes um when the i think the reality is that a very large chunk of students learn how to get an acceptable grade from a class, instead of learning the actual content of the class. Certainly, this was my approach. Because if I wanted to, the two things are often at odds um uh if i wanted to both really learn something from the class and also get a good grade like those were two separate things in many cases because the ways in which we have to like you know assess student performance in classes I just think are like horribly inefficient and
我对课程有意见的原因之一是因为课程是有成绩评定的。我理解为什么对学生进行成绩评定是必要的，但我认为当现实情况是很大一部分学生学会了如何在课程中取得及格的成绩，而不是去学习课程的实际内容时，它并不会产生理想的结果。当然，这也是我的方法。因为如果我想的话，这两者往往是相冲突的。如果我既想真正从课程中学到东西，又想拿个好成绩——在许多情况下，这是两码事，因为我们在课堂上评估学生表现的方式，我真的觉得效率极其低下。
so at least for me as a student instead of like learning the content I figured out what I needed to do to get, you know, the best grade. And not even that, I learned what I needed to do to get, um, uh, you know, a grade that was acceptable to me because I didn't have, you know, I didn't have time to do more than that. And, and, I mean, to be fair, you know, I, I worked full time the entire time I was in college. So that, that certainly might, you know, contribute to my, my frustration here that I was never a full-time student. And when I say work full-time, I meant like, really, I would work like, you know, 50, 60 hours a week. You know, maybe, maybe a bit less when like my last few semesters. But I also think that the fact that courses are graded make the teacher-student relationship very different. different, that there's always an inherent conflict there.
所以至少对我来说，作为一个学生，我没有去学习内容，而是弄清楚了我需要做什么来获得最好的成绩。甚至不仅仅是那样，我弄清楚了我需要做什么来获得一个对当时的我来说可以接受的成绩，因为我没有时间去做更多的事情。而且，说句公道话，我在上大学的整个期间都在做全职工作。所以这肯定会导致我的沮丧——我从来不是一个全职学生。当我说是全职工作时，我的意思是，真的，我每周要工作 50、60 个小时。你知道，也许在我最后几个学期稍微少一点。但我也认为，课程有成绩评定这一事实，使得师生关系变得非常不同，其中总是存在着一种固有的冲突。
You know, is a student really interacting with the professor to learn or to improve their grade or to get the professor to like them so that they, you know, score something that is going to be treated subject subjectively like an essay better um and uh and so i think that it becomes hard for students and teachers to build actual real mentor mentee bonds that you need to really learn something when there's this arbitrary grading system. And also, I think the required curriculum that a lot of schools have, I think is just sort of nonsense. Especially there's a lot of schools
你知道，学生与教授互动究竟是为了学习，还是为了提高成绩，或者为了讨好教授，从而在诸如论文这样会被主观评判的事情上取得更好的分数？因此，我认为当存在这种随心所欲的评分系统时，学生和老师很难建立起真正的心手相传的导师关系，而这是你真正学到东西所必需的。此外，我认为许多学校要求的必修课程纯粹就是无稽之谈。特别是还有很多学校
that still require some core curriculum of something. I know I, at least in college, had to take some number of classes that I had zero desire in taking and that I only took because I was essentially required to. And I do not think that you're going to get great outcomes out of students that are taking a class merely because they're required to. I'll actually push back on that a little bit. I used to think the exact same thing. Like my father is a journalist, I think it's been mentioned before. So he's a big writer. And I'm a big,
仍然要求某种核心必修课程。我知道我在大学里不得不选修一些我毫无兴趣的课程，我选修它们仅仅是因为基本上这是强制要求的。我不认为让那些仅仅是因为被要求才去上课的学生能取得什么好结果。实际上，我会对此进行一些反驳。我以前也这么想过。我的父亲是一名记者，我想之前提过。所以他是个出色的写作者。而我是一个精通数学的人。我讨厌写作，或者我应该说我不讨厌写作，我讨厌任何涉及个人观点的、会影响我成绩的课程形式，这就是为什么我真的很喜欢数学，因为数学不是主观的。如果你在做某种计算，得出正确答案还不够。老师还要评判你得出答案的机制。是的，我的高中数学老师就是那样。我鄙视那种方式，因为，你知道，他们会看到一个看起来像带小帽子的数字 1，但实际上它是数字中的一个数字 7，而其他所有东西都完美无缺。然后他们会说，嗯，你这里有一个 1。这是错的。我会想：我其他所有答案怎么都对了？
I was a math person at the time. And I hated writing, or I shouldn't say I hated writing, I hated any form of course that someone's opinion, it was involved with the grade that I was getting, which is why I really liked math, because math was not subjective. If you were doing some sort of calculation, there was the right answer is not sufficient. And so the teacher is going to judge the mechanism by which you came to the answer. Yeah, I mean, I had a math teacher like that in high school. And I despised I despised that because like, you know, they would see what looked like a one with like a little hat, which was actually a seven as one of the digits of a number and like everything else was perfect. And then they'd be like, well, you have a one there. That's incorrect. I'd be like, how did I get everything else right?
那明显是个 7，只不过我没在上面划一小道杠而已。总之，我认为在很大程度上，数学和物理之类的学科主观性要小得多。而如果你是为了一门哲学课程写论文，那就完全是，你知道，他们觉得你写得怎么样。话虽如此，我最后还是不得不修了两门定性课程或 W 课程，也就是写作课。我最终选修了一门历史课，那可能是我学到最多东西的课程之一，因为那是我的生命中第一次——非常可悲的是——有人花时间教如何批判性地分析一则论文的来源，不仅是谁写的，而且是：什么时候写的？当时的背景是什么，全球范围内发生了什么？直到那时，我才知道存在着左翼、右翼的媒体来源，直到那时我才意识到，每次你阅读某些内容时，你都应该去核对：这个人去了哪所学校？他们来自哪个思想学派？他们是自由主义者吗，等等等等。直到我生命的那个阶段。那是我教育的最后一个学期。所以那是 2014 年。我当时 24 岁，
And like, that's clearly a seven, except I just didn't put the little line through it. Anyways, I think for the most part, for the most part, math and physics and stuff, there's a lot less subjectivity. Whereas you're writing a paper for, you know, a philosophy course, it's just completely, um, you know, how do they think you did? Um, that being said, I did end up having to take, you know, two, uh, qualitative or W courses, which are like writing. Um, and I ended up taking a history course and that was probably one of the courses I learned the most from because it was the first time in my life, very sadly, that someone had ever taken the time to teach how to like critically analyze a sort like the sources of a
我以前从没学过这些。而这来自于选修了一门课外课程。所以我父亲总是说：哦，对，那是为了培养全面发展的人。我会觉得：简直是垃圾。这对我以后找工作或赚更多钱没有任何帮助。但我认为，试图鼓励那种全面发展确实有一定价值。我勉强承认这一点，因为我其实并不完全反对这一点。但我的观点更多是——我的观点其实是，你的选择往往非常有限。我其实可以接受那种要求你接受通识教育但又不像某些学校那样进行强制规定的学校系统，比如——我一听到任何与医学相关的东西就会感到极其不适，真的非常不适，比如说，如果我去打针我都会恐慌发作。而路易斯安那州立大学要求我们选修两门生物学课程。我敢肯定原因在于……
paper, you know, not just who wrote it, but like, when what was when was it written? You know, what, what's the context around that that period of time, what was going on globally, like, and it wasn't until then that I had any idea that there was these, you know, left wing, right, ring, wing, you know, media sources, and that, you know, it wasn't until then that I realized every single time you read something, you should be checking, you know, you know, what school did this, you know, person go to? Like what school school of thought are they coming from? Are they libertarian, blah, blah, blah, up until that point in my life. And that was the last semester of my education. So that was 2014. I was I was 24 at the time,
好吧，这太蠢了。是的，但我来告诉你原因。因为这绝对出现在其中一门课程中，其中一门课程包含进化论章节。这里是路易斯安那州，州里有很多宗教人士。所以我敢肯定，路易斯安那州立大学只是不想让任何没有接受过进化论教育的人毕业。事实上，我想有这样一场考试，为了通过考试，你必须基本上表现出对进化论的理解和接受。但我当时在课堂上绝对度日如年，有些章节甚至让我感到恶心，光是坐在教室里就让我难受，我根本不想待在那里。如果你对我说：选修一门在你主修领域之外的科学课——我确信我真的很喜欢地质学，我可能会去选修一门地质学或其他别的课程。但是，许多这样的大学学位规划非常非常教条化。我不知道
I'd never learned that. And that came from taking a course that was outside of the courses. And so my dad would always say, Oh, yeah, that's for a well-rounded education. I'd be like garbage. Like it's not going to help me make, you know, it's not going to help me get employed or make more money in the future. Um, but I think there is some merit to trying to encourage that kind of, uh, well-roundedness. And I say that reluctantly because like, I, I kind of, I'm not entirely opposed to that, but my, my, my point is more point is more that your options are often very limited. I could be fine with a school system that required you to have a broad education, but did not prescribe it to the same degree that, uh, uh, that, you know, some schools do, um, like, uh, um, so I, I get really, um, squeamish around anything like medical
这真的对任何人有帮助吗。是的，我认为在西蒙弗雷泽大学（SFU），我经历的所谓“广度要求”。要求非常非常少。所以我想你必须至少选修两门 Q 课程（代表定量）以及一些专注于逻辑的哲学课程，这些都符合条件，所以你甚至不需要修数学之类的课程。你还需要修两门 W 要求，也就是写作课程——我想我之前说成是定性课程了——因此，作为一个数学学生，我必须选修 W 课程，而艺术专业的学生则必须选修 Q 课程。我不认为——我觉得这还可以，就好像，你知道，这无可厚非，我大概也能接受这一点。
related, like really squeamish, like, you know, like I get panic attacks if I go to get a needle. And LSU required us to take like two biology courses. And I'm pretty sure it's because... Okay, that's silly. Yeah, but I'll tell you the reason why. Because it definitely came up in one of the courses where one of the courses has an evolution section to it. And it's Louisiana where there are many religious people in the state. And so I'm pretty sure that LSU just didn't want to graduate anybody who had not
有关联，比如真的特别晕针，你知道的，比如我去打针都会恐慌发作。而路易斯安那州立大学要求我们修大约两门生物课。我很确信这是因为……好吧，这很傻。是的，但我会告诉你原因。因为这绝对出现在其中一门课程中，其中一门课程有一个关于进化的章节。这里是路易斯安那州，州里有很多宗教人士。所以我很确定路易斯安那州立大学只是不想让任何没有受过进化论教育的人毕业。
been educated about the theory of evolution. And in and in, and in fact, I think there was like a certain test where like to pass the test, you had to, um, you had to like essentially like, like show your understanding and acceptance of the theory of evolution. But like, I just like, I, I was absolutely miserable in that class. Um, uh, uh you know there were like sections of it that just like would make me like queasy like being in the classroom and it's like i just had no desire to be there um you know if you told me like take some some science class that's you know outside of your main area like i'm sure you know i really like geology i probably would have gone taking like a geology class or like something else but you, a lot of these college degree plans are like very, very prescriptive. And I don't know
而且，事实上，我记得好像有一个特定的测验，为了通过这个测验，你必须，嗯，你基本上必须，比如，展现出你对进化论的理解和接受。但是，我，我，我在那门课里简直痛苦不堪，嗯，你知道的，里面有些章节真的让我觉得很不舒服，比如在教室里，就好像我根本不想在那里，嗯，如果你让我选一门主修领域之外的科学课，我确信，我真的很喜欢地质学，我可能会去选地质学或者别的什么，但是你瞧，许多这样的大学学位规划都是非常非常死板的。我不知道这真的对任何人有帮助。
that really helps anyone. Yeah, I think at SFU, Simon Fraser, I went like the breadth requirements is what they called them. It was very, very small. So I think you had to take at least two q courses which stood for quantitative and like some philosophy courses that focused on logic like those qualified so you didn't even really need to take math or anything like that and you needed to take uh like two w uh or or yeah w requirements which were like the writing one so i think i said qualitative before but um and and so like as a math student it was the w ones that I had to get and then like the the art students had to take the cue um and I I don't I don't I think that's acceptable as like you know it's not it's it's probably would have been fine with that
是的，我认为在SFU（西蒙弗雷泽大学），我去的那个叫广度要求。要求非常非常少。所以我认为你必须至少修两门q课程，代表定量，还有一些专注于逻辑的哲学课程，那些符合要求，所以你甚至不需要真的修数学或类似的东西，你需要修嗯，像两门w嗯，或者，是的，w要求，也就是写作要求，所以我想我之前说过定性，但是，因此，作为一个数学学生，我不得不修w类的课程，然后像艺术学生必须修q类，我不认为这有什么问题，就像你知道的，这可能，我大概也能接受。
but but you know LSU was much more prescriptive yeah that's uh and I just thought of an example of the like monitoring software that they have to use when they're in virtual classrooms? I have not personally read or had to do that myself. I do know people, though, that when they were taking licensing exams in like the last couple of years that, yeah, they've had to have their webcam on and like they've got it's and it's it's just i've the stories that i've heard are absolutely horrifying yeah it's like it's absolutely draconian and and you know it's not always the professor's like choice to do that but in some cases the professor is doing that because they don't want because
但是，但是你知道，路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）的要求要死板得多，是的，这就是……我刚刚想到一个例子，比如他们在虚拟课堂上必须使用的监控软件。我自己没有亲自读过，也没有不得不那样做过。不过我确实认识一些人，他们在过去几年里参加执照考试时，是的，他们必须开着网络摄像头，而且就像是……我听到的那些故事简直太可怕了，真的，就像是绝对的暴政，而且你知道，这并不总是教授的“选择”，但在某些情况下，教授这样做是因为他们不想，因为
they're worried about the student you know cheating or scamming them or doing something. And, and that's sort of what I'm getting at is that like, because of, because classes are graded, there's always this confrontational and transactional relationship between students and teachers. And how can you, you know, how do they expect people to learn from somebody when it's set up like that? Yeah. The space that I've heard about it in is for medical students. And on top of what medical students are going through, like the stress that it was like causing the people that I knew, like it was just, yeah. Draconian is an amazing word for it.
他们担心学生作弊、骗他们或做出什么出格的事。而这正是我要说的，因为课程是有评分的，学生和老师之间总是存在一种对抗性和交易性的关系。你怎么能……你怎么能指望人们在这样的设定下向某人学习呢？是的。我听说过这种现象的领域是针对医学生的。除了医学生正在经历的一切之外，比如它给认识的人带来的压力，真的是……“暴政”这个词用来形容它再贴切不过了。
And it was just, it was so unnecessary. And the scheduling, because usually the tests are taken in person. And just the whole thing was just a nightmare. I, one time, the first year of C++ Now, we had a, was he a high schooler? No, it was the second year of C++ Now. The first year of C++ Now, we had this high school student who came to the student volunteer program. In the second year, he had graduated high school and he was in college. And C++ Now is scheduled in an unfortunate time for American college students because it's in May.
而且这完全是没必要的。排期也很痛苦，因为通常考试都是线下进行的。整个过程简直就是一场噩梦。我，有一次，在 C++ Now 的第一年，我们有一个……他是高中生吗？不，那是 C++ Now 的第二年。在 C++ Now 的第一年，我们有一位高中生来参加学生志愿者项目。到了第二年，他已经高中毕业并上大学了。而 C++ Now 的举办时间对于美国大学生来说有点不太走运，因为它在五月份。
And for a lot of students, it ends up being the week of their finals or like the week right before their finals. And so this kid managed to get all of his, he scheduled to take all of his exams early with all of his professors, except for his Calculus 1 professor. And his Calculus 1 professor did not want to allow him to take the exam early. Again, not late. He was volunteering to take his final exam early. And his calculus professor didn't want him to do that because there was a possibility that he might then share
对于许多学生来说，这正好是他们的期末周，或者是期末周的前一周。所以这孩子设法搞定了所有事情，他跟所有教授都预约了提前考试，除了他的微积分 1 教授。他的微积分 1 教授不想允许他提前考试。再说一次，不是迟交。他是主动提出提前参加期末考试。而他的微积分教授不想让他这样做，因为存在一种可能性，他可能会把
what was on the test with other students and then cheat. So no, the professor insisted that he had to take the test at the same time as everybody else. And so we finally worked out a settlement where the student volunteer came to the conference, but then during the prescribed time when everybody else was taking the test, he would take the test in my hotel room. and I somehow got volunteered to be the person to proctor the test. I had never met this professor before, but for whatever reason, this professor who had never met me just trusted that I would be, you know, that I somehow would be a more trustworthy person than this very bright, intelligent and trustworthy student of his that just wanted to go, you know, go to this excellent career opportunity. Um, but no, he couldn't be trusted to, to, uh, take the test early or to take the test himself. Um, no, there had to be somebody there to supervise, to make sure that he was not cheating. Um, and that was just, you know, that particular professor, I think was a
考题内容分享给其他学生，从而作弊。所以不，教授坚持认为他必须和所有人同时参加考试。于是我们最终商定了一个解决方案：这名学生志愿者来参加会议，但在规定大家考试的时间里，他在我的酒店房间里考试。而我不知怎么的被推选为监考人员。我以前从未见过这位教授，但不管出于什么原因，这位从未见过我的教授居然相信我，会觉得我……不知怎么的会比他那个聪明、懂事且值得信赖、仅仅想去追求一个极好职业发展机会的学生更值得信任。嗯，但他不能被信任去提前考试或独立考试。不，必须有人在场监督，以确保他没有作弊。而那只是，你知道，那个特定的教授，我觉得有点
little bit, was a little bit much, but I think the system made him that way. Yeah. Oh boy. I sound like a conspiracy theorist. Well, no. So, so I'll just, I'll go back to just trying to give my summary of my take on, on university. So I, you know, I had good profs. I wasn't a, um, I wasn't a huge fan of the system. That being said, um, I absolutely loved the end. Like I really feel like I'm, I'm, you know, it's hard to be aware of the opportunity that you have when you're in university. I think it's different for you cause you were working 50, 60 hours a week. I worked during the summers and when I was on co-op and internship, and that's how I paid my way through school. But like while I was in school, if I did have a job, it was only ever taking up
有点过分了，但我觉得是体制把他变成了那样。是的。天哪。听起来我像个阴谋论者。好吧，不，所以……我还是回到最初对大学的总结上来吧。所以，你知道，我有过很好的教授。我不是这个体制的狂热粉丝。话虽如此，我非常喜欢那个结尾。就像我真的觉得，当你身处大学时，很难意识到自己拥有的机会。我觉得对你来说可能不同，因为你当时每周要工作 50、60 个小时。我在暑假期间以及参加带薪实习（co-op）和实习时工作，这就是我支付学费的方式。但我在学校期间，如果我确实有工作，那也只占用了
like 10 hours a week. Like I worked in residence for a while sort of helping out, but it was a very low overhead job and actually ended up like you did that job and then you would get free residence for the semester while you were working. But basically the thing that I would say is like the friends and the community that you are exposed to there. Like I just finished reading a book called Together by Vivek Murthy who is the 19th Surgeon General of America. And it's about loneliness and like the increasing rise of loneliness in like the world, partially due to social media. And at one point they-
比如每周 10 个小时。比如我在学生宿舍工作了一段时间，算是帮帮忙，但那是一份开销很小的工作，最后的结果是，你做了那份工作，在工作的那学期里就能获得免费住宿。但基本上，我想说的是你在那里接触到的朋友和社区。我刚刚读完一本书，名叫《在一起》（Together），作者是维韦克·穆尔蒂（Vivek Murthy），他是美国第 19 任医务总监。这本书讲的是孤独，以及世界范围内日益加剧的孤独感，部分原因社交媒体。而在某个地方，他们——
Partially due to this whole pandemic thing. Well, actually, so he wrote the book and was publishing it right as we were going into the pandemic. Oh, wow. And he has a little bit like in the foreword, yeah, that talks about like, you know, I didn't even had no idea this was coming. But yeah, it's makes it even more as you just said. You said he was a doctor. He's part of that.
部分原因也是因为这场大流行病。嗯，其实，他写这本书并在我们刚进入大流行病时将其出版。哦，天哪。他在前言里稍微提到了一点，是的，谈到了诸如“我甚至根本不知道这会发生”。但是的，正如你刚才所说，这让它更有意义。你刚才说他是个医生。他是其中的一部分。
I will not be a part of promoting whatever conspiracy Bryce is trying to shill right now. But at one point, my favorite part of the book is when he, there's these three studies that identify that there's like three different types of loneliness. And the first one is intimate. And that's like wanting someone to confide in whether that's in the form of a partner or a really good friend. Then there's relationship slash friendship. And that's like your group of, you know, close 15 friends. And then there's what they call collective loneliness is like not being a part of a community of sort of like a larger purpose. And I think that like, university is like the best opportunity, it was the best period of my life to find like all three of those at the same time. Because like, you're, you're a part of these classes, and that's the collective,
我可不会参与推广布莱斯现在试图兜售的任何阴谋论。但有一点，我最喜欢书中的部分是，他提到了三项研究，指出了三种不同类型的孤独。第一种是亲密孤独。也就是渴望有人倾诉，无论是伴侣还是极好的朋友。然后是关系/友谊孤独。这就像是你那群亲密的 15 个朋友。最后是他们所说的集体孤独，也就是没有参与到一个有某种宏大目标的社区中。我认为，大学是最好的机会，它是我人生中找到同时拥有这三种孤独解药的最佳时期。因为，你是这些课程的一部分，这就是集体；
you end up making great friends, that's the relationship. And then for many people, they end up, you know, whether it's ends up being long term and permanent or, you know, intramurals and activities that you get to do. And it was, um, that part of university, like I absolutely loved. And, uh, yeah, I, I never, I never really had that. I mean, when I was at LSU, um, I, you know, I never lived in student housing. I was working all the time. Um, and like the, really the major, though, was that I was at a different phase in my life than than other students. Like we were I was maybe one or one year older than or two years older than some of my classmates. But, you know, I was working full time, you know, like sort of I was I was an adult. But I think like if I had gone to take a class at a
你最终结交了挚友，这就是关系。对许多人来说，他们最终，无论是长期的、永久的，还是你参与的校内体育和活动。而且，大学的那部分经历，我是绝对非常喜欢的。而且，是的，我从来……我从来没有真正经历过那些。我的意思是，当我在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）时，我从不住在学生宿舍。我一直在工作。而且，真正主要的原因是，我当时的人生阶段与其他学生不同。就像我们……我可能比我的一些同班同学大一岁或两岁。但是，你知道，我在全职工作，你知道的，就好像我是一个成年人。不过我想，如果我去社区学院
community college, I probably would have had more like with people, you know, who had full time jobs, who, you know, like in my class at a community college, I probably would have had more in common with those students than with, you know, students, you know, undergrads at a large party school who just had very different interests and priorities than mine. But even when I, you know, the college I dropped out of was a school called Union College in upstate New York. And even when I was like there, like, and I was living in student housing and I was not working full time, I just never really had that connection. You know, my, my community was always some collection of people that I knew online before it was programming folks. It was, you know, various gaming communities, but by that time it had started to be programming folks. So I always sort of like had that community, but it was just never, it was just never that college community. Yeah. I guess. Yeah. It depends where you're coming from. Like I, I came from a smaller city and was always like, uh, I never fit in, in high school. And, you know, I liked going to math clubs and doing a math contest and stuff. And, uh, there was very few people that I clicked with. Um, Benjamin Chung was one of them. He was my math rival. Uh, he ended up going to University of Alberta and getting a biomedical engineering degree. But then when I showed up at university, like
上课，我可能会有更多共同语言，和那些有全职工作的人在一起。你知道的，就像我在社区学院的班里一样，我可能和那些学生有更多共同点，而不是和大型派对学校里那些兴趣和优先级与我截然不同的本科生。但即使我……我退学的那个大学是一所位于纽约州北部的学校，叫联合学院（Union College）。即使我在那里的时候，我住在学生宿舍，也没有全职工作，我也从来没有真正建立那种连接。你知道的，我的社区一直是我在网上认识的一群人，早期的编程朋友。那是各种游戏社区，但到那时已经开始是编程朋友了。所以我总是觉得有那种社区，但它从来都不是那种大学社区。是的。我猜。是的。这取决于你来自哪里。就像我，我来自一个小城市，总是……我从不合群在高中。而且，你知道，我喜欢去数学俱乐部，参加数学竞赛之类的。而且，能和我合得来的人寥寥无几。钟本杰明（Benjamin Chung）就是其中之一。他是我的数学竞争对手。他后来去了阿尔伯塔大学，获得生物医学工程学位。但是当我出现在大学时，
the first day of orientation, which was like the week before university, it was all students that wanted to be either statistics or actuarial science majors. And I was just like, wow, I've never met so many people similar to myself. And yeah, to this day, like I'm one of my best friends is Steven, who I met on that first day. And, you know, when we that's the thing is we we do virtual board games every once in a while. And like we were playing Catan the other day. And that's like, these are the kind of people that are like working through the statistical odds of like, okay, what should I do? What's statistically like the best outcome, you know, in there? They take board games like, I can play for fun, but I like playing board games more like, you know, really taking it seriously.
迎新第一天，也就是开学前的一周，全都是想主修统计学或精算学的学生。我当时就想，哇，我从来没见过这么多和我相似的人。是的，直到今天，我最好的朋友之一史蒂芬（Steven）就是我在那第一天认识的。而且，你知道，当我们……这就是事情所在，我们偶尔会玩虚拟桌游。我们前几天还在玩卡坦岛（Catan）。这就是那种会去计算统计概率的人，比如，“好吧，我该怎么做？从统计学上讲，最好的结果是什么？”他们对待桌游就像……我可以为了好玩而玩，但我更喜欢认真对待的桌游。
And actuaries and statisticians, most of the ones that I've come across all sort of bring the same rigor to the calculations that are done while playing board games. Anyways, this is going to be a long winded episode of, wait, so have we answered one, should you go to university and two, should you drop out? So I think the answer is drop out, probably not, especially if you're two, three years in, just finish it. Or maybe we should have a whole other episode on should you go to university um yeah although if we if we do that we're gonna get letters from parents you're gonna get letters from parents i think especially in canada our education system is doing a lot better than america's no offense um yeah and uh but before we go there you know it's um you know i i didn't i didn't i was i was one of
精算师和统计学家，我遇到的绝大多数人，在玩桌游时都会对计算抱有同样的严谨态度。不管怎样，这将会是一个长篇大论的一集，等等，所以我们回答了一，你应该上大学吗？二，你应该退学吗？所以我觉得答案是：退学，可能不要，特别是如果你已经读了两三年了，那就读完它吧。或者也许我们应该专门做一期节目讨论“你该上大学吗？”嗯，虽然如果我们那样做了，我们会收到来自父母的信。你会收到来自父母的信。我觉得特别是加拿大，我们的教育系统比美国的要好得多，无意冒犯，嗯，是的。而且……但在我们深入之前，你知道的，我……我不是……我是其中一个
the like you know i wasn't a popular kid in high school but i went to like a science and engineering high school and uh yeah yeah we we've told it's a it's pretty epic high school yeah that's the middle school the middle school middle school was great that was the weird funky private middle school but i went to the science and engineering high school after it which was a magnet school and um there was you know there was a a group of people that were more you know sort of my type people who were interested in science and um you know i i had plenty of friends there um uh you know i had some of them who had been um people who had we'd gone to elementary who had, we'd gone to elementary school together, then we'd gone to middle school together at the private middle school.
就像你知道的，我在高中时不是个受欢迎的孩子，但我去了一所科学与工程高中，然后，是的，我们说过，这是一所相当史诗级的高中。是的，那是初中，初中，初中很棒。那是那所奇怪的时髦私立初中。但我后来去了科学与工程高中，那是一所磁铁学校（特色公立学校），然后，你知道，有一群人更符合我的类型，他们对科学感兴趣，然后，你知道，我在那里有很多朋友，有一些人是我们一起上过小学的，然后我们一起去了那所私立初中。
And then we'd gone to this magnet, this science magnet school together. So like, I definitely had some friends. I wasn't, you know, the loneliest kid in the world. But I was raised as an only child, you know, with a single mother. So I sort of was always, always pretty comfortable, you know, being a single mother. So I sort of was always, always pretty comfortable, you know, being on my own. But I'm not really, I'm not really in touch with, with any of those folks anymore. Once I went to college, I just sort of fell out of touch with, with all of them. And I made some friends when I was at Union College before I dropped out. But I have not been in touch with any of them since I dropped out.
然后我们一起去了这所科学磁铁学校。所以，我确实有一些朋友。我不是世界上最孤独的孩子。但我是在单亲妈妈的抚养下作为独生子女长大的，所以某种程度上，我一直挺习惯……作为一个单亲妈妈的孩子。所以某种程度上，我一直挺习惯一个人待着。但我真的……我跟那些人都不怎么联系了。我一上大学，就和他们所有人失去了联系。我在联合学院（Union College）退学前交了一些朋友。但我自从退学后就再也没有和他们中的任何人联系过。
When I was at LSU, I made like, I think maybe one at most friend, but maybe there was like one or two people that I- Was that your biking buddy? No, no, no. I'm just talking about other students that I ran into in classes. I had plenty of friends who were coworkers at the research center. And I had, there were plenty of friends who were co-workers at the research center and i had there were plenty of you know undergrads or graduate students who were also who were my co-workers who i was friendly with but not really anybody who i ever had classes with um and yeah i mean it's my oldest friend is somebody that i know from a gaming community
当我在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）时，我大概只交了一个朋友，或者可能有一两个人我……那是你的骑行伙伴吗？不，不，不。我只是在说我在课上遇到的其他学生。我在研究中心有很多同事朋友。我有，在研究中心有很多同事朋友，而且我有很多本科生或研究生同事，我和他们关系很好，但真的没有人是我一起上过课的。而且，是的，我的老朋友是我从一个游戏社区认识的人，
that i've never actually met in person who I've known since like I was 12. Yeah. And like, you know, yeah, it's, it's, it was funny. Cause like I realized a while back, like he's the person I've probably known and had continuous conversations with the longest. Um, but yeah, it's just, I never, I never really had good connections with the community until I, uh, until I found my way into programming and met the, you know, made all my friends that I now have in the programming community. So, yeah. Yeah. Different stages, different stages or phases of your life.
我实际上从未在现实中见过他，从我 12 岁起就认识了。是的。而且，你知道，是的，这挺搞笑的。因为我前段时间意识到，他可能是我认识最久、并且一直在保持交流的人。但是，是的，我只是……在进入编程领域、结识了现在在编程社区里的所有朋友之前，我从来没有真正与某个社区建立过良好的连接。所以，是的。是的。不同的人生阶段，不同的人生阶段或时期。
You're going to sync more with people. I guess I got to mention Chris Gieske too. I mentioned Ben, but yeah, Chris, Chris was my science fair. We went to, maybe that, that should be an episode one day. Not that people care. Maybe not. I went to three national science fairs. Yeah. That to maybe that should be an episode one day not that people care maybe not I went to three national science fairs yeah that's definitely going to be an episode
你会和更多人同频。我想我还得提一下克里斯·吉斯克（Chris Gieske）。我提了本（Ben），但克里斯，克里斯是我的科学展搭档。我们去过……也许那，那可以成为某天的一集节目。虽然人们可能并不在意。也许吧。我参加了三次全国科学展。是的，这……也许那可以成为某天的一集节目，虽然人们可能并不在意。也许吧。我参加了三次全国科学展。是的，那绝对会成为一集节目的。
thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。